all these people are blowing up piano
player I believe that if I put hard work
in
that I would get better at something
what does that tell you
Jesus Christ uh you know just being a
good guy because even when I was a
criminal my motto was always to make
somebody's day some days it meant yeah
me robbing you but you know if I made I
didn't make your day but I made my day
and I was having a good time but I
wasn't really feeling fulfilled you know
like it was just falling I went out to
dinner this podcast is brought to you by
on it
on it.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like pressing code Joey
and get 10 off delivered right to your
house what's happened you Savages it's
Monday March the 6th
the joint is brought to you by steps.com
listen
2023 is taken by and nobody's got time
it's already March the 6th who's got
time to go to the Post Office for stamps
and whatnot especially if you're running
a small business you need stamps.com
easily print postage from home or the
office they'll even send you a free
scale so you have everything that you
need we've been with them with
stamps.com from over 12 years me and my
wife tremendous easy
with postage rates on the rise
stance.com could offers the lowest rates
in the industry set your business up for
Success when you get started with
stamps.com sign up with promo code Joey
for a special offer that includes a
four-week trial plus free postage and
free digital scale no long-term
commitments or contracts go to
stamps.com Click the microphone at the
top of the page and enter code Joey the
joint is also brought to you by manscape
listen you know manscape has your balls
covered Thank God now they can make your
face look skinny as your package with
the brand new bid edger Pro kit to be in
hedge it gives you 20 hair cutting
lengths all out of turn of a dial no
more changing out attachments it's
waterproof so you can change even that
you could shave in the closet and
manscape beard and oil and beard Palm
will keep you looking
Barbershop fresh and since manscape
wants you to have all the tools for the
job they're throwing in a beard brush
and a comb and scissors to make you look
like a million bucks get 20 off in free
shipping with code Joey at manscape.com
that's 20 off and free shipping with
code Joey at manscape.com that's
manscape be it hedge approach it the
premier solution
do your face grooming the joint is also
brought to you by voila blue chew
2023 is the year to up your game and
Bluetooth can help blue Choo is an
online service that delivers Ed medicine
straight to your door with the same
active ingredients as Viagra Cialis and
Levitra at a fraction of the cost
listen I love blue shoe why it's in your
pocket
you bump into a victim you make a look
up in the sky at a birdie you pop the
blue shoe and you're ready to sling
Bluetooth wants everybody to have better
sex Discovery options at bluetooth.com
chew it and do it Jack they got a
special deal for the for the joint
family try Bluetooth for free and use
promo code Joey a checker it's gonna
cost you five dollars free to try
Bluetooth are you kidding me that's
bluetooth.com promo code Joey who
received your first month free visit
bluetooth.com for more important details
and safety information and thank
Bluetooth for sponsoring The Joint let's
get this party started Jack
foreign
[Music]
what's happening you Savages it's Monday
the 6th of March what does that tell you
Jesus Christ where is the time going
it's already March the 6th it's crazy
but it was a great weekend it was a
great week last week I'm feeling good
everybody's doing good congratulations
to Jon Jones last night you know I made
a video on Saturday for you guys I talk
a lot of [__] you know
and I always push DraftKings and whatnot
I love DraftKings It's been a you know I
didn't mess around with sports for the
whole time I was doing comedy I was so
focused in on it and now you know I I
enjoy like the little [__] things I
got left I enjoy just to watch a game
from time to time it's not like I watch
sports all the time but at night
sometimes you know you just the game
start at 7 30. my house don't get going
till nine sometimes I watch the first
quarter of the game
then I do something I try to write jokes
for Lee I try to write in my journal you
know [__] like that nah that's my little
dog I'm always writing jokes to Lee I'm
always listen I can't write in my voice
no more because I don't even know I
don't even know what the [__] my voice
is anymore
so it goes rightfully you know and
that's it and I push him like last night
I gave him a joke he was in Orlando
Saturday night
so all week I was thinking about a joke
for Lee and I'm like what can I do for
Leah for Saturday night because Lee's at
a point right now in his comedy career
he's been doing comedy let's say four
years so what I try to do is I try to
you know give them the easy jokes
but then I'm trying to write jokes for
him that I wrote for myself at the four
year mark and I wasn't ready to say
I love people like Jerry what the [__]
are you talking about sometimes you
write a joke
that's so strong
that you're not
you're at a level that you're not
prepared to deliver it and you'll
deliver it
and
you'll say it 50 times you'll giggle but
nobody else gives a [__] about your
stupid joke and you'll throw it away but
in time you'll realize that that joke
was maybe written a little too strong
for where you are talent wise and it
happens all the [__] time
so I wanted to test him this week
so I go you know what let me give him
like a [__] racy joke he's in Orlando
there's a joke I've been working for
like three years
I don't have the balls to say
and it was it came and it went so it was
an old joke but you could still use it
in a late form and it was when the gay
guy in the post nightclub shooting in
Orlando he shot all those gay people
like 90 people so one day I was sitting
and I'm like man if he shot all those
people there's got to be some gay ghosts
around people who got stuck on the
[__] Frontier who didn't make it all
the way to heaven or hell or whatever
the [__] their mission was to be gone
I go so that means when you go to
Orlando there's got to be gay ghost
wouldn't that be funny if you're in your
room at Disneyland also you hear like
boo you know you're like what the [__]
and it's those gay ghosts that got shot
so I it's not a great joke and I haven't
set it up yet but last night I called
Lee and Saturday night I call Lee and
I'm like hey bro [__] uh this is a
good joke for you to try we would die in
a laughter on the phone I don't know
what the final conclusion was what joke
he was going to try you know I sell I
told him if he'd try this joke they'll
definitely not have you back which is
always a good sign
sometimes it's a great sign when a club
doesn't have you want to have you back
you don't know that at the time but
sometimes it's just a dingy bar or some
club with the owners [__] thinks he's
[__] mitzi's sure and he's not
so that's part of my sometimes at night
I just write a [__] joke from Lee I
think there's something you know and
I'll open up his mind with it because
sometimes it's not a joke that you could
use but sometimes it's the the choice of
opening your mind you know I subscribe
to uh uh a betting newspaper it cost me
dollars on the sense just so I could
read about sports because I'm not I
haven't really caught up to it
do I think do you think I use their
picks not at all they sent me pics every
night I don't gamble every night do you
think I use their picks no you know why
I read their pics so it opens up my mind
sometimes they'll just say listen look
at this guy he scored 30 points in four
games maybe tonight he's gonna go under
30. I'll think about it sometimes it's
just opening your mind you can't tell
that joke it's funny because
last week I told uh what had happened
what the anxiety that drove me to
you know just everything that was going
on for the podcast but one of the things
that I also want to address
is something that somebody else said to
me recently they said that about two
years ago before the pandemic they
reached out to me
for a spot at a comedy show and I told
them no and they thought that I was uh a
liar that I don't help other comics and
I was reading the thing because I had
heard that before that people were mad
at me a young Comics were mad at me like
when I say pick up the phone and call
people and then I use a story when
somebody called me and I didn't know how
to really break that down for people
and it's all broken down by the
intention
the intention okay
when I was a young comic likely four or
five years yes I was impressionable I
was impressed by Comics like
you know Carlos Mencia Doug Stanhope
Wendy Liebman
Jackie Flynn there was a complete
different stock a stand-up comics that
were on the working circuit then Rocky
LaPorte
you know Andrew Dice Clay was just
finishing up a huge [__] uh
massive Arena tour Roseanne was blowing
up all these people were blowing up
we didn't have the camera
we didn't have a lot of things we didn't
have the the phone with the video in it
we didn't have a lot of those things
so it was hard work based whatever
you're gonna do it's always hard work
based whether you're going to be a
[__] piano player whatever the [__]
when a comic would come to town like
Felicia Michaels did in 94.
I got a guest set to Felicia Michaels
and afterward I went up on stage during
the guest set
I Bond whatever but I didn't go down
there
for Felicia to save my life
are you with me here
I didn't go down there
for somebody to save my life
I always knew that nobody could save my
life I knew that if I believed I didn't
know this I believe that if I put hard
work in
that I would get better at something I
would get if I put hard work into
anything I believe I'm gonna get better
on it right so
first big comic I met that wasn't big at
the time but he was big was Doug
Stanhope he was big to me he was doing a
lot better than I was I was an emcee and
he was a feature in my world he didn't
need to be on TV he was doing a lot
better than me when I met Doug I didn't
know that Comics took other comics on
the road I didn't know any of that stuff
I was right
I was just impressed with Doug and his
skills
um
when we finished the Show Doug was
talking about if I knew a hotel in the
area to stay in and I'm like yeah but
listen but I don't know what you're
getting paid here tonight but it's
probably not a lot why don't you stay at
my house when I offered that to Doug I
didn't offer that to Doug for him to
change my life I offered to Doug as a
[__]
as a [__] uh you know just being a
good guy I want to save you 50 bucks
because even when I was a criminal my
motto was always to make somebody's day
some days it meant yeah me robbing you
but you know if I made I didn't make
your day but I made my day
but you know that was basically it so I
helped him but I my intentions were pure
when he came back a year later he was
headlining I was still on MC and I was
impressed with him even more and I still
didn't ask him I didn't even know what
to ask him I would ask him a few
questions about stand up I mean what is
dislike you know [__] like that and then
other Comics I became friends with you
know when the trip will run I worked
there for two years two Comics came in
that's 104 Comics a year that's 208 in
three years I worked with and I don't
remember any of them passed seriously
there were all those Comics were
Headliners in 1991 and they were
probably in their 40s and they probably
went it's a triple run so when you're a
headline you know a triple one it's not
that your career is on the way up I
don't mean to disrespect anybody when
you're a young guy and you're doing
triple runs your career is on the way up
but when you're an old guy like me doing
triple run just because your career is
in the [__] toilet so those guys that
I worked with were probably moved on to
something else I'm not mad at them I'm
not saying anything bad about them
and that's why I stood and I stayed on
that path to whatever I didn't open up
for a comic ever
till I got that way
I think Paul Rodriguez asked me to open
for him Rogan asked me a couple times
but when they asked me to open for them
yes I wanted to make a good impression
so they could continue taking me on the
road but I wasn't going to commit to
just them taking me on the road I was
also going to do my work on the side
keep hustling work and whatever work
they had was an a cherry on the Sunday
you know that that's that's all I'm
putting it so
I went to The Comedy Store after that
and yes I became friends with Joe Joe
was on news radio again I did not become
his friend because he was on a TV show I
became his friend because we were Comics
working on the same [__] goals he was
a lot
ahead of me but that didn't change who
my goals were I still had to keep
[__] working
and that's my story on that for some
reason
and guys I hope anybody who asked me for
help comedically and I'm very honest
with them and I'll tell them what's
going on
but I saw this the last couple years and
I was in Los Angeles and the last couple
years that I was on tour
people are looking to get saved that's a
different story than help
Lee syat was always looking for help he
was not looking to be saved Mike was
looking for help he was not looking to
be saved
that's a big difference
I became friends with a lot of when I
was first started doing the church you
know I would talk to a we had a Google
messages like Google page I think
Felicia set it up dog I would wake up
with a hundred [__] messages a day
and I would answer every one of them and
50 of them were stand-ups wanting advice
and I would answer every which one of
them
and I started noticing I was getting
this one email from this one guy
and he was the best comic in the world
and you know like I mean it was [__]
mind-boggling the [__] I was reading
and I had like 10 of these guys that
they were the best comics in the world
they were going to do this they were
going to do that they were going to
change the world with comedy uh but they
wanted my help
like I can't wait to get to L.A to get
on stage with you okay you know I can't
wait either I I can't wait to see you I
really can't from all this [__] you're
telling me I am [__] excited I am I'm
you know
and then they come to LA and
listen when I went to LA the first
couple weeks
yeah I went up to the store one night
and I happened to know
I knew these people from before I got
there I knew him and see it I knew James
Stevens the third I knew Doug stano but
I knew them from the road
they had seen me working
you followed me they had seen me at
different places when I see you at
[__] uh
Dr Quinn's in [__] Lansing Michigan
and then I see you three months later
and you're I'm in Miami but you're
working at Fort Lauderdale with a
headliner I know and then three months
later I'm in Tempe and you're at the I'm
at the Tempe Improv and you're at the
[__] Phoenix Improv and we see each
other at the airport I could tell you're
putting in the work
I didn't know what these other guys were
doing
so they would come to LA and then
they would go the first question was
Joey can you get me into The Comedy
Store and I'm like
no
I mean I don't even know you
how can I refer you
if I don't know you
you're a [__] scumbag [__] you you
told me you would help I didn't tell you
anything
I just told you I can't wait to see you
and now you want to move in you want to
[__] you want me to fire Lee I had
people tell me finally I want to move in
and I want to be a regular at the store
just like that
I didn't know these people from the
[__] road I never bumped into them on
the road or they'd call me and go oh
they hit me with an email on Thursday
and go Joey you're coming to [__] uh
Kentucky this week can I feature for you
again I don't know you
uh
number one number two
I know Dean Del Rey
I know Lee Syed
I know D'Agostino zoida
I know the one girl that works at the
comedy store with a husband who's a
doorman and she's the ticket girl at the
store and I know that they fight every
week for [__] spots and I know that
D'Agostino's on six seven eight nights a
week in L.A I know Dean Delray is out
eight nights a week in L.A and I know
Lee's out at a [__] comedy Place
paying five dollars a show doing three
shows a [__] night
you know this is the [__] truth to
you I know these guys I know what
they're doing and I know they need rent
money even though they're working their
ass off so I'm sorry that I don't know
you Pete [__] Schmidt and I can't
give you a feature spot and now you're
mad at me and you're gonna tell
everybody I'm a scumbag because I didn't
[__] use you but I used one of my
friends that I know is working hard and
I know is putting the time in unlike you
I had no idea what the [__] you're doing
you're just looking to get on stage do
good and hopefully somebody brings you
to Rogan and and you're that I wish it
worked that way
I wish it worked that way so for people
to get [__] angry with me like Comics
young Comics like he says this about
Comics but he never helped us guys we
have our own Circle to work with already
I have guys that I've known for 10 years
that are doing the work in LA and they
are killing themselves and they are
taking planes to make two halves and
lose money on a plane ticket not many
times I know for a fact Dean and
D'Agostino were breaking even like they
were gonna drop two they were going to
lose 200 bucks by featuring at your Club
so instead I give them money for a plane
ticket I give them an extra money
because I know they're busting their
[__] ass so for you to go around
spreading rumors that Uncle Joey never
helped me with comedy that's pretty
[__] bad and you know how many guys I
did help with comedy in LA and they all
failed me you have any [__] idea how
many gigs I got for people you know many
times I got gigs for people and they
would call me and go that wasn't a good
gig
you just moved here from Iowa where you
were doing gigs for [__] Penguins or
whatever the [__] you were doing
I get you a gig at flappers
like I got a guy a giga Flappers and he
was talking [__] about me and I got them
to give him 150 this guy never made a
dollar in his life
so after that you're like why should I
help people
these people just we have our own little
[__] uh
you have your own little pen you have
your own little boat pad of people and I
love me and I had Eric broker too the
gay guy
that [__] does five cents a
night and sucks three dicks that dude is
working seven nights a week that dude
was doing three [__] sets a night now
he's featuring now he's [__]
featuring at The Improv doc Willis all
these guys
I knew they were put into working
so for you people that I disappointed by
not helping you by not giving you a
guess set because
I guess that was going to change your
life
I guess that's not going to change your
and if you got to remember I got
here's the other thing with guest sets
I started giving out guest sets when I
was on the road Comics would come and
they'd go yeah I've been doing comedy
for two weeks and [__]
I was in San Jose one time
and some comic was emailing me and even
though I had a full lineup I went
against my best wishes
on an early show and put this guy up
me the stage Tech
everybody told this guy seven minutes
we got a full show time seven minutes
do you know what time this guy got off
22 minutes
and this is what I'm saying
when you have a sold out show and you're
doing six of those shows whether it's a
theater in the theater I would never
give a guest set because it no
but when a club I'll give you a guest
set but the problem with a [__] club
is
that once you give out one guest set
you got to give out a guess that every
[__] weekend
and guys my good job is to get in and
out of that
my job is not to keep is by putting 20
Comics up
and
and distancing himself me and me
audience for an hour before I get up
there
I'm gonna walk up to a dead audience
does anybody ever even think of that no
no Joey's a scumbag he wouldn't give me
a guess set does anybody ever think of
that does any of anybody ever think of
how hard I work to get that audience in
here
and I'm gonna have somebody just come in
and insult them you know how many people
come in and go you guys suck because you
didn't laugh at me
these are a [__] this is a real
audience this is an audience that I've
been cultivating for 20 years through a
podcast other shows and I'm gonna let
you come in here with your stupidity and
go up there and say
I'm gonna kick her like the fetus of an
aborted baby you know is that what the
audience wants to hear so do you
understand me guys you're living in a
[__] you know I have to see you
before I put you up I have to know you
that that's that's what anything if if
you're doing a renovation in your house
and and [__] the guy and you're gonna
give the guy [__] five thousand
dollars to fix the door or sink or
whatever the [__] you're gonna check a
reference
right I mean am I okay to say that
you're gonna check a reference
so what am I going to do make you
audition in front of my thing on a
Tuesday on a Thursday night you're going
to show up with eight people
and you're gonna go up there and try to
[__] ruin a show for somebody we
cultivated that audience whether it's me
whether it's [__] Steve Byrne whether
it's Theo Vaughn whether it's Josh Wolf
we cultivated that audience since day
one and you want to come and poach you
know nobody ever asked you to do a guess
set when you have eight people in the
audience let's just keep it at that okay
let's just keep it at that where's the
[__] that call you up
to [__] uh go hey you got eight
tickets sold tonight do you mind if I
come down and do a guest then but you
want to get your ass down there when I
have 400 people so people always
understand we live on a [__] uh jaded
[__] thing here something else
happened this week that was really
[__] interesting
you know man in life you have
great friends you have acquaint you have
so many different things and you really
can't put your finger on what it is with
everybody that you that you have you
know I wish I saw Mike Moore
Mike lives [__] an hour for me I wish
I could call him Mike and go Mike let's
go get a [__] Subway sandwich Mike
let's go do this but it doesn't it
doesn't happen you know we live too far
to [__] hang out
right now I'm living around a lot of
acquaintances and I'm enjoying it I
[__] love it
but a couple weeks ago I gotta I got a
call from a friend of mine
and she goes Hey listen I haven't spoken
to you in a while I know you've been
busy I've been busy traveling
do you mind if we get together for lunch
and I'm like no no and you know when I
moved back here I thought I would see
her a lot more whenever her name is Lisa
I met her in the eighth grade we were in
the eighth grade together and we had a
sports thing in the high school
and I met him hello how you doing my
name is Lisa we had a mutual friend
and then that summer I would see at
North Bergen pool and I thought this
girl was beautiful but I also had no
confidence I like you know
I just didn't think she would ever
date a guy like me so I never even got
her into that room you know I whenever I
saw I would think of my mother that you
can't [__] everybody
you got to keep some women as your
friends and with her yeah when I was 14
I wanted to [__] everybody you know
teachers nuns [__] Bakers I didn't
give a [__] you know when you're 14 you
want to [__] the bakery lady you don't
give a [__]
but I don't know something made me look
at her and go you know what I don't
wanna
even go over that line we'll just leave
it at hello goodbye and I would see her
at North Bergen pool we were kids and I
would love to look at her in a bikini
and you know when she was like going
into freshman year or something because
she was always a year older than I was
and I would just watch with a bikini and
you know
I never even told nobody like it's not
like I liked her as a girlfriend I just
thought she was good looking and I
thought that nothing would ever happen
so I kept talking to him and freshman
year she got better looking and Freshman
Basketball I was playing Freshman
Basketball on the track would have
practiced after freshman basketball and
I would sit there and watch her run
hurdles her and a blonde girl that live
this blonde girl now lives in Old Bridge
and she's a [__] hottie too I haven't
seen her since high school
but I still watch both of them and go
wow they're [__] beautiful the girl I
had a crush on had great legs and
and not even a crush I just thought she
was hot but she was my friend I never
thought that nothing would happen
I kept being her friend and I was
friends with her and all her little
girlfriends and then
my sophomore year right before my mother
died a buddy of mine started dating her
no her girlfriend had a crush on a
friend of mine and this girl came up to
me and she goes let me ask you a
question on the slide
what if
me and your friend Lisa hooked up with
you and your boy d
ude and I was like are you [__]
serious and she's like yeah
and I go bro that girl is not going to
go on a date with me and she's like dog
she wants to go on a date with you you
just been playing like possum with her
trying to be her friend but she wants to
go on a date with you and I'm like come
on I was all [__] excited
so
uh we we're gonna meet on a Friday night
or something
that was the schedule meet but we had be
it had to be on the down low because the
one girl had just broken up with a high
school boyfriend and he was a lunatic
so she's like we've got to do this on a
down low so if we can't do it on
download we can't do it so that Friday
it didn't work out that Saturday was
going to be a Halloween party
and the girl Lisa finally called me and
says listen I'm hooking up with you
tonight and I'm like what the [__] is
she saying you know I had Kelowna and
you know when you're [__] 14 15 you
got cologne on the whole thing yeah
there was no manscape or nothing so
and I went to a party and somebody came
to the party and said she's around the
corner another party waiting for you
and that girl that came to get me as we
were leaving that party her boyfriend
pulled up I told that story and got into
a fight with her and jumped her and I
had to pull him off her that was the
night so I never got to
this [__] girl to swap Spit with this
girl or hold hands or whatever I was
gonna do
that my mother died and we went to a
different [__] uh dilemma I didn't
see her then she started dating a guy
and then one time we were down the shore
and we would talk because we were good
friends like we were just friends I had
never hit on her all this [__] had
happened like a year earlier we were
supposed to hook up and now it's a year
later and we're still friends but she's
dating a very dear friend of mine a
[__] guy that we used to call like
Godzilla he was so [__] big
and I'm talking to a dinosaur and
somebody told him
they were up like all night talking and
we we weren't up all night talking she
had gone back through something at like
six in the morning and I was still up in
the night before and we were in a
[__] living room down to show all the
[__] house just [__] and somebody
told the guy so he came and threatened
me stopped talking to when I'm like
dog I was sitting there with three
friends and she came in and started
talking to us which was the truth
and then she was embarrassed so we
didn't talk for like another year
it was the craziest [__] thing in the
world then they broke up and they
started breaking up in high school and
then she would talk to me and I was
still a little upset about the [__]
thing when I talked to it I didn't try
to hit on her or nothing so I kind of
stayed away from him one day she just
[__] I was living with the runners
and she just came over and she's like
listen man
I know we've had a a bumpy history you
know but I I I'm very fondy and I'm
sitting there going I got no money I'm
living on my friend's basement what is
this girl talking about
you know why did she [__] continue to
I don't know I don't know we never had
sex nothing
but we used to talk
and then
when I moved with the running she lived
around the corner so we made a deal that
we'll work out every night
right like we would get back in tune and
work out so we would go to Hudson County
Park where the Martians landed
and we'd run around the lake every night
and then on the way home we'd stop at
Carvel and we'd smoke pot and we just
talked and if anybody knew my deepest
darkest Secrets at the time it was her I
was going through hell with my
stepfather I was going through hell
without my mother I was telling her all
this [__] that I was going through and
then it came time to graduate high
school and she was dating a guy because
she went back with that same boyfriend
so she was it was like an apprehensive
relationship with me now but finally one
day she told the boyfriend who was a
dear friend of mine who I went to
grammar school with what the [__] was up
and he finally goes I get it all right
you guys are friends and we were we
[__] definitely were friends in the
whole time there was one time we thought
about swapping spit but we were friends
man and good friends like just good
friends and we started going out at
night we were all going out in the group
me her six other girls nothing ever
happened we go out snort coke smoke pot
I mean we were having a good time we
were [__] kids you know
and then I went as I was getting ready
to go to Colorado in 83.
I started talking to him more and more
she was unhappy
with her boyfriend at the time she was
unhappy with like her career and [__]
like that
and we would you know we would talk in
the afternoons we'd go get an assaway
sandwich once a week at night we'd be
together I mean two nights a week she
was with her boyfriend but the other
five nights she was always with me
and I don't know it kind of got a lot a
little weird before I left we started
going through those conversations and
dating again
but you know what I had to get the [__]
out of here I was dying I wasn't making
any progress
so I [__] left and I left on April
21st 5th 1983 which is her birthday so I
still remember getting the car and
giving like a birthday card and hugging
her until I'd be back soon and [__] but
I wasn't coming back I didn't know what
I was doing and when I went to Colorado
to Aspen we talked every week every week
we were talking on the phone for like an
hour how you doing and she was
struggling I was lonely not being around
my North Bergen friends and [__]
and finally I came back and I mean if I
got back on a Sunday night I saw her an
hour or two after I landed and we were
inseparable for those two weeks and
nothing happened
and that was she was one of the reasons
that I [__] stayed it was her and let
the music play that song I heard that
song out at my friend's house and I'm
like how can I go back to Colorado with
this music playing the coke is so good
the Quaaludes are bumping what am I
gonna do in Colorado ski but the real
reason was I wanted to get you know I
was ready for a girlfriend a full-time
girlfriend
so when I came back we made the mistake
and started [__] dating and I loved
him and she loved me man we were having
a great time but you know what
we went to drugs I was into drugs she
didn't know how bad I was into drugs
and after a couple months it just didn't
work out you know I was [__] homeless
half the time sometimes I had an
apartment
I think the worst thing I did was after
she we broke up she [__] hated me and
I kept trying to force the hand and I
tell you what it wasn't that she hated
me as much as she was disgusted in me
because I had the World by the balls
when I was doing drugs and I wasn't
paying attention and everybody was
trying to offer me jobs and I wouldn't
take them so I'll never forget I took it
to a New York Net Camp the Nets were
playing the Sixers or somebody out here
at The Meadowlands it had to be November
of 84.
I was in bad shape I had picked up an
ounce of coke
at 11 in the morning and now with seven
o'clock at night and I was down to a
half ounce of coke and I took it to this
game and at the first period I've talked
about this before I got up to get his
drinks and I ended up getting the
[__] waiter coked up at The
Meadowlands Marina I got up in the
beginning of the first quarter and I
didn't come back with two minutes left
in the game she was pissed
she made me drive a home she told me to
[__] off and the whole thing and I was
[__] heartbroken and then uh
at the end of my uh homelessness
I ended up going to a party like
December 29th or something like that of
84.
and she was there with a new boyfriend
and I made a [__] jerk out of myself
I started crying the whole [__] thing
you know I'm not I'm not embarrassed to
say so we're all [__] idiots from
time to time
listen man I was homeless I was in bad
shape physically and mentally and I just
put a lot of Hope into it and I and I
knew how much she liked me you know and
that night we had a little bit of our
argument I said [__] I'm not going to
talk to her no more I can't believe she
did this to me in my lowest point
I moved to Colorado and years later when
I was about to get married one of my
friends came to the wedding and he
pulled me aside and he goes amen
I talked to Lisa the other day she sends
her love and she says
to call her before you get married
and I was like what
and she goes call her before you get
married she wants you to call her and
talk to her before you commit to this
marriage and I'm like
I'm not calling that [__] [__]
you know I'm not going to call her I
ended up getting married
and then years later I got divorced and
then
when I came back here 30 years ago
I got a job working at a deli I was
embarrassed I didn't want anybody to
know
and one day as I'm walking out to get in
the car she's outside and she's like hey
man what are you doing
she's like I heard you're back in town
and you're working here and
I told her how embarrassed I was and uh
and the [__] whole thing and
you know we became tied in that way she
picked me up that night and she
introduced me to a husband she goes I
want you to meet my husband you know
he's a good guy he wants to meet you I
told him all about you and I met him and
I got it you know I got I wasn't jealous
I wasn't upset I wasn't anything
she had done great with her life you
know
and then I left and I started doing
comedy and she would come to my shows
her husband and I wasn't very good then
but she would support me this before
anybody would come to my shows she would
come to shows when I was a [__]
feature act and [__] she would go to
bananas and [__] uh the other place
in West Orange
I forget what his name anyway she would
go to all those clubs she went to
Secaucus to Houlihan's to see me once
and I got booed
it was always my friend and [__] you
know and
and then uh like about
maybe 15 years ago
my friends were at a barbecue at some
party and some other guys were talking
some [__] about me and she [__] read
them a [__] riot act
like she's like [__] you [__]
you don't know what he's been through in
his life as a kid his stepfather I mean
she knew everything she knew what I was
suffering you know I would always I
would only tell her you know
and I it got back to me that she stuck
up for me and I called her up and I go
hey man
I heard what happened at that party I
know who was talking shitty about me and
I know that you went on the [__] hook
for me thank you and she's like don't
worry about it they don't know dick blah
blah blah so this girl had my back when
there was nothing
there was no storytelling there was no
Longest Yard there was nothing she was
already telling people go [__] yourself
he's gonna do great shut the [__] up
what have you done with your life I mean
she was already batting for me
so when I got Spider-Man too
I got invited to the caster and crew I
really couldn't do nothing you know I
just took my wife cast and crew is like
a [__] Washed Up Premiere you know
without the lights and the photographers
and [__] you just go there they don't
give you nothing to eat they don't give
a [__] about you but I you know I don't
give a [__] but for the longest yard
they told me I had I could bring eight
people
I don't know if you guys know this I
brought seven guys and one girl and that
girl was my friend Lisa
because she believed in me so [__]
much
I couldn't I didn't even take my wife
that I [__] Premiere but I took this
girl to that man that's just to let you
know
I took her to that one I took I think uh
six of my friends and one of the
teachers
I think I took Mr T to that one
and then for the
Grudge Match for me in New York City I
brought Mercy's Godfather I brought Mr T
no I brought Mr Barone my other teacher
and I brought Lisa she never brought her
husband to any of the premieres she
always went with me and for the many
Saints in Newark premiere
I brought Lisa
because
I don't remember I don't forget [__]
guys so
when we got here when I got here was
covered and I really couldn't see her
even though she lives 25 minutes from me
she has parents to the road and she was
like Coco I love to see you and the baby
and your daughter but I can't because I
gotta go see my parents and their old
you know everybody was scared about
their parents now nobody gives a [__]
but uh
so we didn't really see each other a lot
during the pandemic and then we got I
she came to the premiere of uh
she came to the premiere September 22nd
she came to my house here one night uh
to dinner with her girlfriends and I had
a little get-together here and she said
she'd stop by she went to El Nido
and then she came to a with a husband to
El Nido and she stopped by she came up
by the house and I talked to both of
them but then I haven't seen her you
know so it was weird because I was like
you know what man she's one of my
friends that
this just went away you know listen we
all grew up everybody's busy with their
own lives
and she called me for my birthday and
she goes hey man I didn't forget it's
your birthday I'm gonna be busy this
weekend and next weekend but can we do
lunch on a Wednesday and I was like
absolutely first of a little
apprehensive I didn't know if I had to
do the [__] audio book or what the
[__] I was doing
and we went and met guys I got there at
12 15.
I forgot I was there and at three
o'clock she says it's three o'clock I
had a [__] run out of there to meet
Mercy
that's how involved we were in our
conversation it was like
it was like I it was like we had no time
between us or sitting down because we
were sitting at the bar
we used to go to Hudson County Park and
we used to sit at the park bench and
we'd look out into the river
and we just talked without looking at
each other so a lot of times this week
when I was eating my meal I was talking
and we were talking and I wasn't looking
at her and I kept thinking about us
being kids at Hudson County Park I was
like wow this takes me back I mean this
is
1980 [__] four three we used to walk
around that [__] Lake in the winter
there's some we're going 40 Back 40
[__] years with this person that's 40
[__] years and you figure five years
before that going to clubs and eating
Quaaludes and jumping up and down and
[__]
but
she knew my
frame of mind for a long time and I told
her I never lied to her I told her what
was in my head what was in my heart
she used to go joy I'm just going to
Coco she doesn't call me Joey at all
she goes I'm gonna [__] pray for you
but this Wednesday we just talked about
life family
what happened all those years you know
what happened to our friends what
happened to our relationships with them
and I left there I don't know I can't
even tell you what I felt when I got in
the car
and I can't even tell you how I felt
that night but the next day I woke up
and I had a a missed call from her and I
called her back and I go hey man did you
fall asleep after lunch because I came
home I played with Mercy for a while my
wife got home and I told them all I
gotta take a nap I think I got all
proteined up from the meal I don't know
what the [__] happened I think just uh
we were both so excited we hadn't seen
each other that after we left she said
she passed out she couldn't keep her
eyes open and I came home and fell
asleep for a [__] hour that's how
great it was just to see her and I tell
people all the time man listen I really
enjoyed talking to my therapist when I
needed Dana from bed out I had a great
time talking to her
I think the best therapy is just seeing
somebody that knows you inside and out
sometimes and just talking
we didn't discuss any of our problems we
just discussed what we had been through
the last year you know what she had was
going through with her parents her dad's
85 he can't drive I remember working for
her dad
okay
my dad was a [__] animal
when I used to bartend in the city you
know I'm snorting coke so I could use
every dollar I can it didn't matter I
was making 600 a week and 300 and tips
that wasn't enough for my lifestyle [__]
no so I had to paint bathtubs
you never heard me telling those stories
and her father
got put in a halfway house when he was
younger
for bookmaking
in New Jersey you can't book make as a
felony
great [__] story and while he was at
the halfway house they brought him to a
small business convention
and he bought a franchise on
bathtubs like people who come to your
house instead of you buying a new tub
they resurface it
and they painted and they guarantee it
and you got a new [__] tub
and when I met him he had been out of
the halfway house like 15 years already
20 years but the business had grown he
had like four guys working for him so
one day I'm over there with him and he's
like you look like a big guy you know
Lisa's boyfriend you should come work
with me and I'm like okay so I would do
it
Monday nights
and Saturdays and Sundays
[__] great job guys
showed up with a truck I pulled out
paint and another [__] milk container
and a compressor I would go in the
bathroom I would wash the tub
with the [__] you know women's gloves
those plastic gloves I would wash the
tubs
and then I would dry the tub and then I
would have to put some acid on it
for 20 minutes and then I would have to
wash the tub off
I do all the prepping I would wash the
tub out get all the acid off the tub
make sure all the old paint was off and
then I have to paint you know when you
paint anything you gotta [__] tape it
off and put paper I would do that and
then I'd go get him a 12 pack of
Budweiser in cans I could get two six
packs of Bud and cans the coldest ones
and I bring them back and he had a
cooler already with an ice block on the
bottom he's the guy who taught me how to
drink Budweiser colds I love Budweiser
bee I don't give a [__] about your HMO I
don't give a [__] about your ije you
know those beers people drink what are
they what do they call the IAB or
whatever the IPA I don't give a [__]
there ain't nothing better than the
Budweiser when it's cold than it can
there's no beer that's better than that
or second honorable mention a [__]
freezing Heineken
freezing Heineken that gets put into a
ice cold mug listen go [__] yourself
with your ijp or whatever the [__] you
call it
nothing better than the cut this
[__] would put two cases of two
six packs of Budweiser and a [__]
cooler on a sheet of ice and then put a
bunch of ice on top but he'd have like
three or four left so by the time I come
back with the beer we could start on
that one and by the time we got to this
one and I shouldn't say we unless he had
a mouse in his pocket because I only got
to drink one of those [__] he
would only give me one I was only
allowed to drink one after I did that
whole process I would crack that [__]
Budweiser and he would do he would drink
the another 11 Budweisers in the time it
got to paint it and seal it and then
once I did the [__] whatever I was
done I would just take the tape off he
would [__] wash it with some water to
seal it and we would get the [__] out of
there so it was three hours
total maybe two and a half hours three
hours there was stairs and he would pay
me like 85 bucks so I was making 250 a
week just from her father and if I if I
got into a Coke pinch I could ask her
father to give me an advance and I would
work it off so one time we broke up and
I owed him money and she's I'm like I'm
not paying and we broke up and she's
like you got to pay my dad I don't care
if you don't want to date me no more but
you got to pay my dad so I had to
[__] do the bathtubs while I wasn't
while she was dating somebody else that
sucked dick but it was uh
yeah she called me the next day and
she's like can we talk and I'm like yeah
and she goes bro
that was [__] phenomenal
she goes I'd go on away with trips I I
do this I do that I go to concerts and
that's the best three hours I've spent
with somebody in a long [__] time
and we just talked about our lives and
what had been going on but like I'm here
to tell you man I love therapy I love
talking to people about [__] when I have
it going on
but there's always that one [__]
friend that is better than therapy she
really is better than therapy you could
just call her up tell her what's going
on and she'll just tell you what's
happening with your life and that's what
happened this week it took an outside to
look at me and go this is what's going
on with you she goes I see it right
see you're right in front of me she goes
I I saw you before you went to prison I
I know you when you were a kid I saw you
before you got into drugs I saw you
while you were on drugs I saw you before
you went to prison before you were
homeless after you were homeless and she
goes you're doing the best that I've
ever seen you
she goes you shouldn't worry about
anything I mean she goes you look
healthy which thank you you guys keep
telling me I don't feel that [__]
healthy I gotta pee every [__] 15
goddamn minutes so I don't feel that
[__] healthy but it's just great
I think that
what I said I wanted to come back here
and reconnect with friends I think it
meant friend I think it meant I really
like her a lot since Wednesday we've
talked like maybe three times
about different things in life she's you
know she's thinking of retiring her
husband's retiring in April I mean it's
just like we met each other at a
different part of the [__] Bridge
and it's just great to know that you've
had friends for that long that you've
kept it together you know I was starting
to feel a little I don't know ever since
I got back here you know my friends all
have their own lives now and stuff like
that and I had to put that all into
perspective
it's not when we were kids and we were
going to [__] six of games and three
nights a week it's all changed we all
have families and we all have
obligations but I gotta tell you some
man it's important and you and when I
got back in I was going out to dinners
with friends
like uh three or four buddies at the
time we would go out to dinner and I was
having a good time but I wasn't really
feeling fulfilled you know like it was
just falling I went out to dinner
this year they felt like uh
I think I have to do more one-on-one
like a felt I got something out of it
and uh
she got something out of it and so did I
so
if you have a good friend maybe this
week is a good week to [__] call them
somebody haven't spoken to in a while
that knows you inside and out because we
don't really think about these people a
lot in our [__] busy worlds maybe
they're going through something and you
haven't called them in a while maybe
it's time to call that person I'm happy
that
just sometimes talking about just
talking about what's going on in your
world with somebody who knows you
with no obligation you know sometimes
you have like an aunt they're related to
you you know I could talk to my wife
she's known me for 23 years but this
girl knows me when I was
the happiest I was when I had a mom she
knew me with my darkest time she knew me
and the struggle and now she knows me
now that I accomplished becoming a man
and
with all of the doubts I had for and I
didn't have many of them lately but I
think meeting with her and just talking
with her for that three hours made a big
difference and all I want to tell you
guys the Monday motivation is that you
know those friends you haven't heard
from in a while because of the pandemic
the pandemic [__] up [__] for a lot of
[__] people
and it [__] up [__] for me and my
communication with some people some
people took it the wrong way or whatnot
listen if we haven't talked to somebody
in a long time and you've been like uh
a breath to this person check up on them
this week
in fact I'm gonna check up on a couple
guys this week that's time that uh we
were friends since grammar school and
ever since I got back here
I've said we're gonna get together from
Ray Canelo to Mr Barone my teacher you
know I'm gonna bring him a copy of the
book
so I think that doing that last week
really put a [__] uh really put a
wind in my sail and maybe it'll help you
out maybe you don't need a win than
yourself I don't need dick Joey I just
need the sling dick and smoke pot maybe
you could have that too it's March
[__] six [__] this is the
month Monday motivation have a great
week stay black and don't forget
amazon.com you can pre-order [__]
tremendous the Uncle Joey story that's
it and that's that I love you
[__] and now for a word for my
[__] sponsors
all right I want to thank you little
[__] savages for coming on on Monday
thank you for the little morning
motivation call your friends [__]
the ones that mattered I thought they
should had ones anyway the joint is
brought to you by manscape listen
you already know manscape has your balls
covered like a [__] rug now you can
try manscape beard had your pro kit it
comes with 20 different hair cutting
lengths for your face you're gonna look
how beautiful and the taller the turn of
the dial you don't got to change out
attachments are nothing plus it's
waterproof and you could change anywhere
and manscape's gonna send you some beard
oil and beard bomb that will keep you
looking like a [__] doctor and since
manscape wants you to have all the tools
for the job they're throwing in a brush
a comb and scissors to make you look
like Johnny [__] Ventura before the
operation so get 20 off and free
shipping with code Joey at manscape.com
again that's 20 off from free shipping
with code Joey at manscape.com
the manscape beard Pro educate the
premier solution to your face listen
we're showing up with Bluetooth today on
a Monday why because it's that time of
the year when the birds are chirping
it's time to sling dick blue shoe is an
online service that delivers Ed medicine
straight to your door same active
ingredients as Levitra Cialis and Viagra
but a fraction of the cost listen
blue chew is tremendous you don't gotta
go to the doctor you don't got to tell
nobody a lie just fill out some
questions talk to the doc and within 48
hours you'll have a box in your house
and you'll be ready to jump up and down
Bluetooth wants you to have better sex
like a like a banshee discover your
options at bluechoo.com chew it and do
it Jack they got a special deal for the
joint listeners try Bluetooth for free
Troy what are you talking about free
when you use promo code Joey at checkout
just pay five dollars for shipping
that's bluetooth.com promo code Joey to
receive your first month free visit
bluetooth.com for more details and
safety information and the joint is also
brought to you by stamps.com 2023 is
picking it's ticking bite along who's
got time to go to the store to the post
office to get stamps you not me either
especially if you run a small business
you need stamps.com print your postage
from home or office they'll even send
you a free scale so you have everything
you need to send the package out Tip Top
Magoo I've been with stamps.com for 12
years they're the best why because they
save money time and energy with postage
rates on the rise stamp.com offers the
lowest rates in the industry set your
business up for Success when you get
started with stamps.com today sign up
with promo code Joey for a special offer
that includes a four-week trial plus
free postage and three digital scales no
long-term commitments or contracts just
go to stamps.com Click the microphone at
the top of the page and enter code Joey
I want to thank stamps.com I want to
thank Bluetooth and I want to thank
manscape.com but most importantly I want
to thank you [__] for having my
back stay black have a great week and
I'll see you [__] next Monday the
13th love you
[Music]
thank you